you are going to alienate the audience
that has lived with these stories
for decades
we have this quote here we actually have
two quotes i know if you want to turn
around i know we said you weren't
allowed to look at it at first and now
we have the big reveal and uh i'm
assuming you probably know these quotes
maybe you don't but if you want to read
them for our audience i would like to
yes okay great
we made a promise to ourselves at the
beginning of the process that we weren't
going to put any of our own politics our
own messages or our own themes into
these movies in a way we were trying to
make these films for him the author not
for ourselves well that's peter jackson
and he's talking about j.r.r tolkien
and this was
his idea
when they began to work on the lord of
the rings trilogy and
arguably the lord of the rings trilogy
of movies is the most successful
one of the most successful trilogies in
all of movie history
and i say this for a couple reasons one
we don't talk about it very often
and i mean that in a good way meaning
we're not trying to wrestle with its
failure we're not saying well the third
movie didn't land
uh you could say that for christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy you could
say that you could even say that for the
original trilogy for some the the return
of the jedi did not completely work um
so many trilogies or film franchises
you know this is i think where the term
stick the landing came from
and
you know peter jackson was able to do
that and i think it was because he stuck
with this philosophy from the beginning
he trusted in the story he trusted in
the source material
he had the utmost respect for it and yes
he made changes to make it
to make it translatable to the screen in
a way that would appeal to people who
are not fans of the source material of
the original books of which i am one
i've never read the books not to say
that i wouldn't be a fan if i would read
them but um
sword and sandal uh wizardry that kind
of it's not my personal favorite thing
i'm i'm more of a science fiction
buff when it comes to genre material
that i like so the fact that i'm a fan
of the lord of the rings films
because of
how successfully it was pulled off i
think that's saying something
and i think it comes from the
it really comes from that first trailer
the first trailer for the first lord of
the rings film when you go back and
watch the preceding trailers really got
you engaged in frodo's story
and gave you a glimpse into what this
journey would be like and what the
stakes were and also
the music music's amazing but if you
watch that
the original trailers for the original
the very first lord of the rings film
the fellowship of the ring
it's i mean it gives me chills just even
thinking about it
conversely
with
the amazon
series which is being made
for money
which you could argue all movies are you
know all movies are made
for money but i think when
when also it's coming from a a need to
creatively express something i think
that that's much more powerful and and
when you compare the original trailer
for the first lord of the rings movie
with this current upcoming lord of the
rings series the rings of power
it just seems like
no comparison to me
that trailer looks like
dollar store game of thrones it looks
fairly generic
you know there are other criticisms
about the you know the look of it not
being
you know faithful to the source material
i can't speak to that because i've never
read those books
i just love a great story
i
it's not present yes it's a teaser
trailer so let's cut it some slack i am
hoping
that even though this quote is from
peter jackson
that the makers of the new
lord of the rings series would keep
some philosophy like that in mind in
fact that's actually a very good guide
for any person
who is embarking on the journey of
making
a franchise
project for which they did not create
that franchise
that's a good that's a good mission
statement
we have a second quote
no let's read the sentence let's let
let's
okay
uh
it felt only natural to us that an
adaptation of the author's work
would reflect what the world actually
looks like
uh
i believe i don't know who said that but
i believe that
is from the makers of the new lord of
the rings the rings of power
and my concern about that is
that
it's they're already giving themselves
an out to stray from the original source
material
tolkien made a world that looked like
well the world he created i don't
understand why you would stray from that
i i can get
you know what their corporate reasons
are but i think more
a more compelling reason would be the
creative reasons for that it it to me
that statement
that that quote
is an excuse to to
turn it into something that
i mean what are they going to do the
concerns of what are they doing they're
going to put hip-hop music in there
because hip-hop is very popular is that
what they're going to be doing at the at
the you know it's whenever they do that
i mean i've noticed it in previous
franchise well this is especially in
particular music is the thing like well
this is the popular music now so let's
have somebody sing a rap song in a star
trek movie
okay those things always
they never work
and what it does is it dates it
and what i what i what i think that
where it tends to work better is sort of
a timelessness to the storytelling
yeah so
that that second quote
uh
is is really troubling to me
it's it's corporate speak for we're
gonna do whatever the hell we want and
uh
damn your allegiance or love of this
franchise because we're just gonna do
what we think is right and i i don't
agree with that
speaking of tolkien and like old books i
was watching a
quick trailer on a woman who runs an old
bookstore and and about collectibles and
she said basically when we get these old
books we need to take very good care of
them and we need to know we're just kind
of keeping them for future generations
because when we pass on someone else
will be getting this book and we're sort
of like keepers of the book do you feel
like
in some sense it's the same thing with
the storytelling like we're really just
here for future generations making sure
that it's preserved well
i love that sentiment and i hope it
holds but i think we're living at a time
now where
uh
everything creative is being
undone and remade
and not with the interests of preserving
the original author's intention
whatever era that person came from
so
i love that because i am someone who
still goes to used bookstores so i i i
love that sentiment i have concerns that
that the same respect is not being paid
by
the corporations that purchase these
franchises
for the purposes of updating them
and
you know
adding things that
that just don't work they just they just
stand out and they just
like it's like oh they're doing an
update well
that's over
i mean you see it in desperation there
are certain sort of tropes of things
that would happen i mean they call it in
television they call it jumping the
shark right
in the happy days television show when
they did like this two-parter where
fonzie
is something you would never see
fonzie's
uh he's water-skiing and you see a shark
and he literally
jumps
over this this incline over the shark
he jumps the shark this is now happening
in in movies right it happens a lot in
you always knew a franchise was over
when they would bring in a cute
character
in older television shows they bring in
some cute younger character because some
of the child actors had already aged up
it's the cousin oliver syndrome look
that up brady bunch it's a reference i'm
dating myself but like and and they even
made a joke about it in the simpsons
um with itchy and scratchy they brought
in a character called pucci
which was a skateboard riding
you know backwards baseball cap
animal character that rapped and poochie
was meant to appeal to the kids
and that is a very simplified version of
exactly what we're discussing right now
it's when you're updating it to a modern
audience um you're
you're
you run the risk of you know one
creatively it's not gonna it's not gonna
work and secondly you are going to
alienate the audience that has lived
with these stories
for decades and
probably read it when they were younger
and have visions in their mind that are
better than a movie that you could ever
make
so
ah
that that
quote is very troubling to me
the latter one yes that last quote is
very troubling to me